deux mois après le décès de leur maman
l'émotion est toujours présente
une personne rapidement pour pas grand
chose
une opération de cassée et en 5 jours on
est mort voilà c'est ça c'est pour moi
c'est
une histoire qui fait pas grand chose
mais qui fait beaucoup la fin
les enfants ne comprennent toujours pas
comment Claudette a pu mourir à
l'hôpital avant son opération du fémur
24 août elle a eu son bouillon de soupe
elle m'a dit qu'elle avait que la
version bouillon de saut c'est le
dernier repas qu'elle a eu parce que il
fallait qu'elle soit jeune
et tous les jours les opérations étaient
reportées reportées donc quand j'allais
la voir je suis allé l'avoir de fois il
y avait marqué à jeun sur la porte nous
a appelé nous dire que par mangé pas
boire qu'elle avait très mal que qu'on
s'occupait pas d'elle
le CHU de Dijon assure avoir nourri la
patiente en attendant son entrée au bloc
mais la famille n'y croit pas et veut
des preuves moi j'ai jamais vu de
plateau repent dans sa chambre il y a
pas de plateau repas
en début d'après-midi donc
les plateaux repas les enlèvent pas tout
de suite le seul chose que j'ai vu c'est
un brumisateur d'eau minérale juste pour
s'humidifier les lèvres le docteur dit
qu'elle était Agen pendant plusieurs
jours et puis qu'elle a été nourri alors
je comprends pas
qu'est-ce qui est vrai quel âge ou
le médecin nous arrive il nous a dit
l'arrivée en déshydratation totale il
s'est passé quelque chose c'est voilà
c'est une exigence pour moi c'est ils
l'ont abandonné
mais peut-être que j'aurais pu la sauver
quand même
ils espèrent que l'enquête en cours les
aidera à aller de l'avant quand on aura
les réponses ça ira beaucoup mieux après
et puis pour notre petite sœur qui reste
derrière la dernière de la fratrie
on aura montré aux gens à faire
attention et puis dans la détresse il
faut prendre en compte c'est tout